voilà nous arrivons au terme des six
mois à passer ensemble une petite
composition à faire explique m'aider
parce que tu sais qui pioche il peut
alors faire chacun autour de gaza
l'élan est vrai que tu pèses tu ne sais
pas mais qui après si tu le mois autour
de la table et pourquoi je vis de la
question mais contre les meubles c'est
bon là les personnes la casse
personnelle comme ça à temps qui a posé
cette question
le but du jeu c'est qu'on ne sache pas
la vie de ma mère que c'est pas moi
c'est vraiment le truc parce que soit tu
joues pas parce que tu considères que
c'est un jeu de merde tu vois un jeu de
merde tu peu d'humour on n'a jamais fait
de mal
soit tu vas donc tu es super
enthousiaste mais vous avez déjà
même chose
benjamin est ce que ce jeu des russes je
sais pas si je suis encore amusé mais on
voit qui est qui